comunque secondo me ultimamente stiamo
sforando un po con la qualità video
ludica però andiamo bella tutti ragazzi
e benvenuti a questo nuovo video siamo
su west bank i kings per niente sarebbe
rocket league
un attimo sarebbe rocket league con le
sedie e iv c'è non so come spiegarmi
questo gioco ragazzi praticamente cosa
succede io sparo è un rocket league con
le sedie non saprei come spiegarlo
meglio che io sparo per poter colpire la
palla e mandarla in porta io sono quello
questo qua in basso a destra che sta per
segnare che non ha segnato e che forse
rocket league non mi è servito molto
nella vita conto visto smash so cosa è
successo a sono caduto al quando cadi
davis lasciare lo shoot battono che vai
vai vai tiro io ma che reti vecchie reti
no eccolo lo riesco e difficilissima ma
poi rompere lo studio ok va bene io mi
chiedo come cosa si fumi la gente però
vabbè ma basta ma cado sempre io ok no
accaduto anche sconti anche gli altri
effetti prova se ancora nessuno ha fatto
un gol veramente difficile eccolo ci
sono porca vacca questo la buona no
sbagliata direzione dalla mi allineo mi
alleno dritto dritto ma porco lemonia
fritto che ti porta in porta
eccolo la madonna cosa succede uno a
zero sono fortissimo è stato veramente
bello
fam palo quanto bisogna rimane parava
alla madonna che compagni inutile che
ciò una urna è un gioco competitivo c'è
anche in e sport sto gioco lo fanno nei
tornei ma che cosa ho fatto
lo splendido 2 a 1 quando si arriva in
questo gioco incredibile cioè si fermerà
prima o poi questa agonia comunque io
sono il cristiano ronaldo dei giochi
stupidi se questo è
il modo di definirmi 3 a 1 segnato
sempre io e faceva un'altra partita
ragazzi che ancora non dovrei giocarlo
con pietro sto gioco prima o poi lo farò
con pietro non assicuro andiamo ragazzi
altra partita almeno tre gol dall'altra
papara perché quello non fa niente
maledizione ho segnato sempre io anche
nella mia porta no no alzati ok bene
bravo a tutti e due ci siamo fatti
autogol va bene fa niente tira tira
compagno stupido tira tira chiaia a cali
sono stati scontri quindi va bene porco
il demonio che gol ho preso ma che gol
palo ahia
ogni tanto succedono delle robe che non
sono proprio fisiche però vabbè è anche
io su questa sedia secondo me se sparo
mi metta in propulsione funzione non so
come ho fatto a vincere la prima perché
questo è molto piuttosto dicono di prima
e ragazze attenzione porca vacca la
palla buona la quale buona ma come ho
fatto a non segnare
ero davanti alla porta da solo vabbè dai
ragazzi non ci credo per quanti colpi ci
sono i sto cucina a ma tu puoi colpire
gli altri col fucile
ecco come fai a cadere perché colpisce
gli altri ok non capivo e tira 3 1 2 lo
faccio ancora un gol ragazzi è un gioco
difficile questo capitemi da quartirolo
qua porta come la parata aia e fallo
arbitro sezione attenzione è buonissimo
eccolo va bene stavo riuscendo a
sbagliare non so come 3 a 2 e la partita
ce la portiamo a casa bellissimo
bellissimo e stato stupendo
basta ma lei ragazzi sono passato al
lato oscuro perché era un po limitato
quel giochino lì però almeno abbiamo
fatto un po di quello è un po di rock e
allora dicevo in genere quando gioca
rocket ormai io passo le mie giornate a
parlare dei cavoli miei però oggi non
volevo fare questo volevo giocare a
quella roba lì con le sedie solo che si
è rivelato un gameplay veramente corto
quindi per forza devo mettermi a
compensare la lunghezza del gameplay
coro che cli ge
c'è un altro modo allora fermi un attimo
che qua se perdiamo un casino almeno te
visto che un video serio per una volta
solo che prova a fare il serio visto che
sono in classificata tra l'altro aspetta
aspetta questa buona primo gol
very good magari la mamma mia sono
rischiato di non segnare ragazzi va bene
parliamo di qualcosa ne vede ormai
mentre il nostro ufficio carano che
league senza parlare di qualcosa
parliamo di cose perfetto parliamo in
argomento che su youtube non avrei mai
portato tratto non so se vi siete
accorti marshall turco di bit sabre
guarda te l'ho scaricato l'altro giorno
fisso però ragazzi a parlare di un
argomento che non avrei mai portato in
uno dei meridio di rocket league soliti
perché è un argomento un po troppo corto
però va bene perché siamo già più o meno
a metà vive quindi posso portare come
vai ultimamente faccio video molto ma
molto più per me che per gli altri c'è
cosa voglio dire youtube e ragazzi è
cambiata c'è youtube è veramente
cambiata tantissimo e continua a
cambiare perché il mondo del web
ragazzine come la televisione che ci
sono sempre gli stessi programmi dopo
secoli abbiamo preso gol come dei
deficienti andate le trenta anni fa
intitolate pomeriggio 5 comunque il
simile oggi è uguale il web ogni anno
cambia veramente ma forse anche anche
più velocemente cioè non so spiegarmi vi
ricordate il video che avevo fatto
l'anno scorso in questo periodo che si
chiamava youtube sta morendo perché era
uscito l'articolo 13 è passato un anno
incredibile
l'articolo 13 ha avuto effetto non
ancora non ancora perché è stato
approvato alla fine però è stato
approvato ma entrerà in vigore nel corso
di anni quindi da qui a un netto 2 si
vedranno i risultati dell'articolo 3g
speriamo che siano molto molto molto
leggeri rispetto a quello che hanno
preannunciato
detto questo youtube sta già cambiando e
sta già introducendo delle cose vi
faccio un esempio se voi a privati
youtube nel 2013 14
era una piattaforma molto più adulta
rispetto alla piattaforma che è oggi
oggi sapete youtube youtube è diventata
una piattaforma per bambini vuol dire
che la maggior parte del pubblico di
youtube sono bambini non vuol dire che
il pubblico adulto si è tolto è vuol
dire che youtube ha guadagnato rispetto
al pubblico di prima il pubblico
infantile
i b b questo spiega perché canali come
l'hai anime contro te cav h questo
spiega perché lo abbiano ricevuto così
tanti iscritti in poco tempo e il perché
continuino a fare le views così
importanti sulla piattaforma no perché
gli intrattenimenti infantile oggi
pagano di più rispetto all
intrattenimento che posso fare io
all intrattenimento che fanno con quelli
youtuber tipo me questo è quello che
succede oggi su youtube
purtroppo però chi fa video verrà miti
bene contro 3 c'è tra un cpm che cinque
volte il nostro e alle virus che sono
cinque volte le nostre quindi presenti
non si guadagni fatte per 25 credo che
la matematica sia giusta in questo mio
calcolo se non è giusta bacchetta temi
tanto io ho sempre sbagliato tutti i
materiali questo significa che molti
youtuber che hanno il mio pubblico si
trovano a dover fare non solo più
youtube come lavoro dover fare altre
tante altre cose no invece io signor fa
vj che su youtube ho sempre dato il
massimo da quando io canali su youtube
quindi dal 2013
ad oggi quindi sono quasi sette anni che
io do il massimo che riescono su youtube
per portare a casa il maggior risultato
io oggi posso anche permettermi di fare
cose che mi piacciono di più cosa vuol
dire vuol dire che se un tempo pensavo
solo e soltanto al piacere al pubblico
oggi non è più così ma da un annetto
ormai a questa parte io da un annetto a
questa parte sto facendo video che
piacciono a me ok che non vuol dire che
non piacciono voglia non è non è per
forza non è per forza così però per
farvi un esempio molti di voi mi
chiedono ad esempio venerdì 13 no e io e
navi 13 lo porto ma non lo porto tutti i
giorni io sono sempre lo stesso gioco
viene di 13 ok non cambia mai
quindi se dovessi ascoltare il pubblico
dovrei fare almeno un episodio di vena
editrice la settimana almeno uno
ma non lo faccio perché oggi io sulla
piattaforma voglio fare quello che piace
la gente ma quello che piace anche a me
quindi i miei miei video vedete magari
anche un calo di performance performance
rispetto a
ad anni fa raccomandava il mio canale
anni fa che vuol dire che faccio bocca
chiusa e faccio sempre tipo decine di
milioni dismessi non so quante perché
non controllo spesso però ne potrei fare
anche di più ma oggi non voglio solo
fare quello voglio fare anche quello che
piace a me è una cosa che magari gli
youtuber tanti altri youtuber facevano
già da anni
solo che io non ho mai avuto questo
questo approccio sulla piattaforma
sempre voluto fare quello che piaceva
alla fanbase oggi faccio ancora questo
ma voglio portare anche amati quello che
piace a me quindi se vedete un
cambiamento sul mio canale esempio anche
il the morning gaming e col de marie gen
non avrei mai fatto una cosa come il the
morning having rispetto a anni fa però a
me piace fare il the morning and middle
live mattiniere con mickey mi divertono
e bello ci divertiamo tutti quando siamo
lì perché è proprio bello cioè io mi
alzo volentieri dico faccio questa cosa
che mi piace condivido un momento con i
miei ragazzi ok quindi sono io non sto
più facendo le cose solo ed
esclusivamente per il pubblico le faccio
sia per il pubblico che per me ok anche
perché oggi ci si deve adattare a
youtube perché youtube cambia spesso e
noi dobbiamo trovare il modus operandi
per riuscire ad affacciarci alla
piattaforma nel modo migliore ok ma
credo che tante persone abbiano fatto
questo nel corso di anche tipo che ne so
dredd per fare un esempio non lo so è
perché dredd è sempre fatto video che
piacciono però io l'ho sempre visto fare
cose che gli piacciono e del modo giusto
di approcciare la piattaforma cioè non
fare video perché li devi fare fare
video quando chi va di farlo e ti
piacciono è una cosa fantastica comunque
ragazzi ho finito il video di oggi spero
che vi sia piaciuto non posso darvi più
notizia perché non mi sono interessato
troppo all'argomento delle restrizioni
dal 2020
penso lo sappiate già tutti se seguite
le news di youtube perché nell'argomento
ormai già è risaputo risaputo comunque
io non mi sono anche troppi formato
quindi non voglio parlare st parlare di
cose che non so che lo solo accennate
basta per arrivare a dieci minuti di
video così monetizziamo quei due euro i
ppi ragazzi spero mi sia piaciuto come
sensibile mitchell assolutamente mi
piace noi ci vediamo un po se i bisogni
iscritti al canale si sono al
campanellina per le notifiche se avete
meno italy charlie non fatelo non sarà
una sega non è vero
fatelo comunque non ci vediamo come
sempre al prossimo video ragazzi
[Musica]